welcome back to 8701 we're starting a
new chapter now
chapter 9 on nuclear physics and this
video
is the first introduction into the topic
where i'm explaining some
of the terminology and some of the
concepts
we'll dive in much more detail as we go
on
so given an atom you can specify the
number of neutrons the number of protons
and the number of electrons which is
equal to the number of protons for
neutral atoms atoms of the same element
they have the same atomic number z
but they're not all the same isotopes
of the same element have different
number of neutrons so you can have
uranium with a num number of neutrons
varying
um you typically you know write an
isotope
by specifying the mass the number of
protons and the number of neutrons but
that information
is redundant so typically we we simplify
this by just writing things like
238 uranium and that specifies
that specifies a specific isotome of
uranium
when talking about different nuclei we
sometimes refer to them as
nucleate atom nucleus with a specific
number of neutrons and a specific number
of protons
isobars are nuclei nucleate with the
same mass
with the same number of names some of
the same sum of protons and neutrons
but with varying individual number of
protons on the drugs
an isotone is a nuclear with the same
number of neutrons
but with varying number of protons and
an isomer
is the same nuclei but the different
eigenstates which means that
the energy states sorry different energy
state so we can
excite nuclei with their compound
particles
the nuclear radius is typically um can
be extracted
from the mass of the of the nuclei and
it's simply then we add little
balls to the sum and it scales with
um a to the one-thirds
the mass of the number of elements in
this in this
in this nuclide there's many
isotopes there's many nuclei and so you
typically have
uh you can can look at all of them if
you want or subset of them
in nuclear shards as given here where
we've got
z the number of protons and here the
number of neutrons
[Music]
and we'll we'll look at many more of
those charts later
here's another representation of the
very same thing you see in nuclear shard
again
um and here what's plotted in red are
the stable nuclei
we will see that nuclei can decay and
will understand why they decay and in
what form they decay that is the core
part of this of this chapter
it's understanding how nuclei can decay
and what we can learn about them uh by
studying the case
um one way to look at it for example you
see that here
i plot z over a so the number of protons
over the over the sum of the number of
protons
z plus n and you see that
most of the stable nuclei with the
exception of the one with
very small mass number have
less protons
than neutrons so there is an axis of
neutrons it can also be seen here
the stable nuclei are typically on
or below this axis where z is equal to n
radioactive decays can be characterized
typically there is a parent nuclide
and there's a daughter nuclei and so
radioactive decay is a process in which
an unstable nuclei
spontaneous rules energy by emitting
high
particles ionization particles and
radiation
the decay and the loss of energy results
then
in an atom of one type the parent
particle of paranuclei
transforming into an another type of an
item called the daughter nuclei
we have already looked at
[Music]
decay rate in the concept of particle
physics interactions
but we can define this very similar here
the decay rate or sometimes this is
called
decay constant and then as we did before
we can
define the mean lifetime or the half
lime life
of apparent nuclei
so this is it for the introduction and
we in the next lecture
we'll start looking in in the
energy which is used to bind the nuclei
the
the protons and neutrons together and
how we can
understand this from an empirical model
you